this video is brought to you by
brilliant.org
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
last time we took a look at an
artificial intelligence that could write
anything
from news articles to computer code it
could also summarize
information and answer questions based
on the information and not to mention
simulating conversations with people of
the past such as einstein
it's an interesting episode so you're
missing out if you haven't seen it
already
this episode will be a bonus one for
this week
for apple the iphone is a huge part of
their business
this year it's made up about 44 of all
of apple's sales
and the iphone made up 147 billion
dollars in revenue
last year we all take it for granted
but making a smartphone is a complicated
process from raw materials
research and development to
manufacturing production and sales
it's a modern marvel that we can make
hundreds of millions of the things
but in 2020 things are being unsettled
global lockdowns are shaking up
economies and faith in existing supply
chains
there is a need to make supply chains
more robust
to tackle this this year apple the
world's most valuable company
has started ramping up production of
iphones in india as opposed to china
it could mark a significant shift not
only for apple
but for geopolitics and the world
economic hierarchy for the next decade
let's take a look you are watching cold
fusion
in tv of manufacturing apple has
historically had close ties to china
this started in 2001 when the original
ipod was manufactured by foxconn in
china
over time this relationship between
apple and china
only grew according to the publication
maker
china accounted for 90 of apple's
product factories in 2019
then 2020 happened and covered lockdowns
coupled with the china-us trade war has
forced the tech
giant to reconsider but where would they
turn to
well as it turns out the answer may lie
next door india started manufacturing
mobile phones in 2014
and manufactured 150 million in 2019
in fact they are the second largest
mobile phone manufacturer in the world
india has a population of 1.3 billion a
young workforce
and the government that's actively
trying to reboot their economy
so they're showing potential
prime minister narendra modi has called
for a self-reliant india
and wants to encourage local
manufacturing to create jobs
this plan is called the production
linked incentive program
if successful india hopes to revive an
economy that has been battered by
lockdowns
part of the plan is trying to attract
smartphone makers with a 6.6
billion dollar federal scheme an
incentive of 25
on capital expenditure will be provided
for production of electronic components
semiconductors and other parts india
projects that these efforts will employ
800 000 people and lead to exports
totaling 143 billion dollars over the
next five years
this is direct economic competition with
china
and also comes at a time when both
nations are enduring a conflict
at the himalayan border though it could
make
india a global hub for the manufacturing
of mobile devices
if realized this would have a massive
flowing effect in the indian economy
with more people employed and earning
more there could be more demand for
goods
in the general economy which leads to
more economic activity
without increasing debt levels
we all saw what happened to china once
they started becoming the manufacturing
hub of the world
in the 2000s they quickly rose up
through the ranks of living standards
and economic power
if apple's best on india is successful
would other companies follow suit
it's interesting to think about this
local indian manufacturers weigh in
harry omri founder of lava india's
largest phone maker
quote it's a thoughtful move by the
government aimed at wooing apple to
bring significant iphone manufacturing
to india
when the iphone manufacturer shifts an
entire ecosystem
follows the next five years will be
dramatic and india could become the new
china in phone manufacturing
and the bull has already started rolling
in late 2019 apple's largest contract
manufacturer foxconn
started producing the iphone 10r this
was in the southern indian city of
chennai
iphone charges are also being made in
the same region
then in july of 2020 apple's production
in india picked up pace
foxconn announced a 1 billion investment
to expand
iphone manufacturing operations in india
a few days later apple's second largest
contract manufacturer pegatron
registered a subsidiary in india also in
july of 2020
foxconn began manufacturing the iphone
11.
this was the first time that a top of
the line iphone was made in india
and this was a significant event for
apple's supply chain
previously apple only manufactured its
older cheaper models there
apple's iphone 11 will now be made in
india the telecom minister
tweeted with some other phones which are
also being made in india of apple saying
that this is a humble beginning
the iphone 11 is one of the best selling
smartphones for apple and the move
signals a renewed confidence in india's
manufacturing capabilities
and demand in the market manufacturing
in india saves the company 22
in import duties and should apple choose
to pass this on to the customers
it could become a very good option and a
very aggressively priced option
giving tough competition to
android-based smartphones
[Music]
and then in august of 2020 yet another
major milestone
wistron another taiwanese electronics
manufacturer
began assembling apple's latest iphone
se and started a trial production
of the recent iphone 12. the times of
india
reported yet another apple vendor was
looking to shift at least six production
lines from china to india
and this would contribute 5 billion
worth of iphone exports
it is possible that iphones could
eventually be cheaper for the indian
market
but cheaper doesn't necessarily mean
more affordable
we'll have to wait and see what apple
does here
if you're interested in learning about
science and technology
you should check out today's sponsor
brilliant.org
they have a bunch of great learning
courses on anything from quantum
computing to solar technology
and artificial intelligence their neural
network course is particularly useful
if you want to understand how most
common ai works and i don't mean just
have a vague idea
but really understand it they've managed
to make learning fun and interesting
whether you're just thinking of
expanding your scientific thinking or
learning how to program with python
to start learning today go to
www.brilliant.org
cold fusion and the first 200 people
will get 20
off their annual premium subscription
okay so we've seen how india is
positioning themselves to be an economic
competitor to china when it comes to
phone manufacturing
so let's dive deeper as china became the
manufacturing hub of the world
their wages also grew and this priced
the nation
at a disadvantage when compared to
emerging markets
in 1990 the average wage in china was
now it's around 13 000 and this has made
manufacturing products in china
more expensive china's gdp per capita
is 10.1 000 versus 2.2 000 in india
since the cost of living in india is
lower the wages are generally lower
indian monthly manufacturing salaries
are roughly one-third that of china's
despite all of this it's not going to be
easy for india to absorb and take over
manufacturing capacity from china
apple once looked at the nation back in
but found their environmental and safety
standards to be lacking
among the reasons cited were high costs
of setting up factories
a high cost of training workers
inadequate infrastructure
and lack of government support in a
report published by the information
critical components still had to be
imported from china
which still means that china was the
weak point for the supply chain
to highlight this in july of 2020 iphone
production at foxconn plants in india
had to be halted because of increased
scrutiny of chinese imports into the
country
the economic times reported that 100 of
components from china were being
physically checked in india
after escalating tensions between the
two nations so clearly
there still is some work to be done here
it is a long shot for india but as we've
seen
some current iphone 12s are already
being produced
there and this trend is only set to grow
in the coming decade
i don't think apple is stupid when it
comes to major business decisions like
this
with government support encouraging
investment into the nation
india just has to overcome the hurdles
of infrastructure tooling and training
as a result millions may be lifted out
of poverty
from the economic flow and effects just
like we saw in china a few decades ago
so the iphone designed in california and
made in china
maybe more of us will be seeing designed
in california
made in india
[Music]
so let me ask you a question if
investment and manufacturing pours into
india
do you think we could see an economic
boom even half as good as what we've
seen in china over the past couple of
decades
do you think this is likely or unlikely
next week we'll be taking a look at the
updates to huawei
and then the alleged fraud of nikola
motors these are the same episodes i
mentioned last week before i had the
idea to do this bonus video
if you want more cold fusion go and
watch last week's video
so many of you couldn't believe what
you're witnessing
if you want to see anything on science
technology business or history
don't forget to subscribe and follow me
on twitter and instagram
alright so my name is degogo and you've
been watching cold fusion
and i'll see you again soon next week
cheers guys
have a good one cold fusion
it's new thinking
[Music]
uh
you